c'est la fin du jeu il a non c'est pas
possible il y a que trois niveaux trois
niveaux dans deux identique
[Musique]
c'est vous savez ce qui est terrible ce
qui me donne envie de me jeter la tête
contre les murs c'est que même en ayant
pas passé le premier niveau du premier
jeu j'ai quand même acheté la suite non
oh mon dieu
non non puis merde j'ai pas envie moi
j'ai ma dose là ça suffit allez non je
veux pas mais quoi tu le testes pas ah
non j'ai ma dose moi j'en ai marre c'est
bon mais quoi tu es une
mauiette de quoi tu m'as traité de
[Musique]
moviette
personne personne ne me traite de
mauiette tu as compris
personne
[Musique]
oh là là cette tranche on dirait TIG à
mon avis il a dû voir ce qu'il attend
dans le
jeu ce niveau 1 de retour vers le futur
3 sur Master System est sans problème
dans mon top 10 personnel des jeux les
plus dures auquels j'ai jamais joué vous
incarnez le doc qui court après le
chariot de Clara dans le désert le plus
animé du monde il y a genre absolument
tout des mecs qui vous courent après
derrière on sait pas pourquoi des Tomas
qui volent des oiseaux qui essayent de
vous tuer faut ramasser des items qui
traînent par terre ou qui flottent dans
les airs non de je sais c'est pas le
pied sérieux mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu' un symbole égyptien fout
plein milieu du FAR ouest là dans ce
niveau sincèrement il faut des réflexes
de serpent et arrêter de cliner des yeux
pendant 5 minutes pour pas crever tout
le temps entre le moment où les
obstacles apparaissent et l'instant où
ils sont sur vous il doit se passer
genre moins d'une seconde alors
concentrez-vous
[Musique]
bien je suis pas là
il y a personne monsieur grenier il le
chez vous je m'en fous j'essaie
de finir Retour vers le Futur
marchain mais
saute et sa mère e non mais attends
sérieux combiau pour me faire tomber de
cheval moi si je serait toi ben je F
atts attendsss je suis presque allez
cette fois c'est la
[Musique]
bonne allez
oh non oh
non j'aurais aimé être marip pom pit et
moi j'aurais aimé ne jamais avoir acheté
ce jeu de merde et puis même c'est vrai
sérieux si j'allais crever
lamentablement en m'écrasant d'un
falaise je feris probablement un dernier
calambour avant de mourir il y a un truc
qui est super lourd en fait c'est pas
vraiment un défut du jeu mais c'est sur
ce genre de jeu que ça vous prend le
plus la tête c'est que il y a pas de
bouton pause sur les manettes de Master
System le bouton posuse il est sur la
console console qui en général n'est pas
portée de main et je laisse deviner
vraiment ce que ça fait sur des jeux
comme
[Musique]
ça
dans ce niveau je me demande franchement
si Clara ne conduit pas un camion Gifi
parce que le nombre de bordel qui tombe
sur la route si vous voyez il y a des
bottes des caisses des culottes des
porceau de pelouse des chapeau en plus
on se fait chier essayer de choper tous
les items au risque de crever mais la
plupart d'entre eux ça rapporte rien
part des points en fait pas tous allez
ça
avance purée mais regarde charot Clara
là il me met un
vent en fait l'item du réveil sur fond
vert là vous fait perdre du temps en
faisant accélérer le chariot de
Clara c'est hallucinant sérieux un
réveil sur fond vert ça vous évoque quoi
du temps supplémentaire dans toute
l'histoire des jeux les items négatifs
ça a toujours été sur fond rouge ou noir
mais pas vert vert égal positif c'est
évident en plus je veux dire l'item
flotte et donc il est dur à ramasser un
truc dur à ramasser c'est par déduction
un bonus si céit un malus il serait au
milieu de la route il faudrait sauter
pour l'éviter mais sérieusement mais
c'est qui qui a pondu une idée comme ça
j'ai une idée on va faire un malus vert
comme ça les gens il tomberont à chaque
fois dessus tu pass quoi toi
qui qui bon allez niveau 2 on incarne
Marti dans la scène où il lance une
assiette sur ten c'est fou à partir de
ce petit morceau de film qui doit faire
même pas 30 secondes ils ont réussi à en
faire un niveau entier enfin bref à vous
de buter la bandeanel avec l'ARE la plus
dangereuse du monde les
assiettes ici le gameplay est assez
bizarre quand même non non non en fait
il a chier vous pouvez brosser le tir de
vos assiettes mais ça fait bouger Marti
en même temps c'est super relou du coup
quand vous tirez vous vous déplacez en
même temps vous contrôlez rien du tout
vous prenez des balles sans pouvoir les
éviter c'est vraiment de la merde faut
vraiment être P sur le bon pixel pour
toucher vos ennemis là par exemple
celui-là en haut à gauche il est super
dur à choper il faut vraiment balancer
mais les assiettes dans tous les sens
pour réussir à
l'avoir allez
[Musique]
chle
ok ok non c'est bon j'ai rien vu je
cherche pas à comprendre c'est bientôt
fini je laisse j'oublie ce que je viens
de voir he alors si c'est bu fort le
boss franchement il est vraiment ultra
simple parce que on a juste le spam
d'assiette et du coup il a même pas le
temps de
réagir déjà la séquence du train ça
commence à sentir mauvais cette histoire
le hoverboard me dépose sur le dernier
wagon d'ailleurs c mon aurait pu me
déposer direct à la fin enfin bon ce
niveau contrairement au deux autres il
est assez facile il faut juste savoir
qu'il faut ramasser les bûchettes sur le
trajet pour pas se retrouver bloqué
devant un mur invisible le reste c'est
une simple formalité les ennemis meurent
tout seul tuer par la vapeur du train
faut juste avancer sauter sur la laoréan
et hop niveau
fini et voilà je terminé seulement trois
niveaux et il y a même pas de stage
bonus comme pour le de pour essayer de
masquer un peu le V intersidéral non non
c'est rien à c'est c'est encore
plus insultant que pour le de quoi je
peux même pas dire que je je suis
surpris en fait parce que je m'y
attendais c'est mais quand même il y a
pas eu un seul niveau avec la deoréane
il y a pas eu un seul niveau avec la
doloréan alors que la doloréan c'est le
centre des trois films et puis pareil un
niveau bonus super simple à faire ça
aurait été la séquence Marti fait le
stand de tir là le niveau il est absent
sur Master System bon heureusement il
est présent sur le jeu megga driive là
les développeurs il se faisaient pas
chier vu que 90 % des gosses ne
passaient même pas le premier niveau
alors qu important de savoir s'il y a TR
niveaux ou 10 quand tu es bloqué au
premier enfin bref là pour moi je
déclare officiellement que ce jeu c'est
un de cambriolage quoi faites le
calcul 400 balles en moyenne pour un jeu
Master System donc ça fait 800 boules
pour 5 niveaux et deux bonus stages qui
on compte pas le trè level du premier
jeu c'est c'est du vol c'est du vol oh
les mecs plus de suggestions Mario tu
truc
à tu réponse à tous les trucs ça j'étais
content d'être allé voir rour vers le
future 4 aujourd'hui mais là ça de merde
là ça m'a gâché ma journée j'aurais
jamais dû rejoint ce truc
sérieux j'aurais jamais dû ressortir ça
quoi et il faut changer ça et je sais
comment
d'ailleurs vous ou pas je dire est-ce
que je peux rouler sur la route défoncée
oui est-ce que je peux rouler sur mais
bon c'est ball Mar est mal formé du coup
son bras ne fait que 10 cm de long
regardez
[Musique]
ça
ce coupci je les
attends
doucement
doucement je m'énerve quand je joue oh
ça comm for coupe la caméra de
secondes là me font un ver
[Musique]
d'eau
il est
[Musique]
où mission
accomplie
[Musique]